[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
relationships and your work the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'm Ken Coleman joined by Dr John
deloney we're here for you this hour
taking your money questions of course
and then those relationship questions
mental health stuff and then uh John and
I love when we're together we like to
take on those nasty work situations that
involve a whole lot of mental health and
uh and then the money comes in there too
John because people don't want to leave
necessarily a nasty situation but it's
killing them yeah and I I I I was
waiting for today to talk to you about
this stat I saw the other day do you
mind digging into a question I don't
I saw that they they doubled the
expectation in jobs
is that right what do you mean by
doubled the expectation that there was
an expected here's how many jobs we
think are gonna new jobs are gonna be on
the market yeah and it came out it was
double yeah over 300 000 jobs they
thought it was going to be in the 150
000 jobs so again we're in a weird it's
weird job economy because unemployment's
low 3.7 percent uh but people are laying
big companies are laying people off
because there's this thread of a
recession some economists think we're
already in a mild recession uh and so
anyway uh needless to say uh you can
still get a good gig right now uh and
inflation seems to be dipping but the
FED says they're going to raise interest
rates maybe two more times before the
year is out we are seeing now the
Supreme Court ruled just last week that
the student loan forgiveness from Biden
is not legal so now student loan
payments coming on in late August it's
about ready to get into a really crazy
Financial time and all that to say
people who have control their finances
have more margin which means they have
more freedom to Pivot when the economy
gets weird so who knows where we're
going economically John that's a weird
moment these principles work no matter
what kind of economy you're in they work
especially when things get sideways
exactly so we're here for you let's get
to the phones triple eight eight two
five five two two five Brian starts us
off in Cleveland Ohio Brian how can we
help
paid as well and nice thank you guys for
taking my call I was wondering so I am
21 years old and I just bought my first
rental property and I was I just fixed
it up and it's pretty much all we fixed
but my only question is my sister wants
to move in here and I don't like I want
to remove him because you know I'll run
so high I should pay so much in rent but
how do I how do I keep that from
business to the family different and
separate so you I'm getting a mixed
message you said you want her to move in
you want to be able to help her out but
you're worried that it's going to alter
your relationship or do you know her
well enough to know it's going to be
drama
like it's uh it's more of an issue with
how
I don't want you know because our
family's so close and I just don't like
I I would like to keep it separate from
the business and family but I also
really want to help her out do you think
I should or do you think I probably
shouldn't whenever I enter into an
agreement like this and I don't have a
rental property but when I enter into
agreement with something like with a
family member or especially with a close
friend I think the only way through this
is extreme
extreme Clarity on the front end
and making sure you have a separate this
is business this is when rent is due you
got to pay rent all that or this is
what's going to happen on the back end
and letting your sister know I'm gonna
have to run this as a business
um but yes the chances of you running
this into a mess yeah that's that's a
very real possibility when you do
business with family what do you think
kid okay well I actually I'm curious to
know why you keep saying the business of
family and I I think I know what you
mean but I'm just wondering if there's
something else there
um well it's not like this is a family
like you know this is like my
um like that's one of my first
um family members actually bought a
house like one of their kids and so I
just you know there's a lot of like
renters that like a lot of my selling
hours rent and I was like you know I
thought it was a good opportunity you
know if I start buying houses I can rent
to them but
okay
yeah if that makes sense okay so John
dug in I thought on the right thing here
I don't I'm sure we got a good answer
are you worried that you and your sister
uh in this relationship now it changes
when she becomes a renter from you and
you are her landlord are you worried
about that in general because of the
nature of how the relationship changes
or are you worried meaning it could be
any family member and you'd have the
same question or are you worried
specifically about this situation with
her that's what I'm curious about
um I'm more worried about this situation
here that's what makes sense well I
think John saw I think you heard that
and and so
um when when John asked you that and now
that we get some clarity on that I think
you need to listen to that red flag what
specifically if it were another family
member uh you wouldn't have pause what
about this particular relationship
causes pause
you know I bought this house and
and talking about it she said she was
gonna save a lot of money and that was
gonna be really good you know it'd be
really good for both of us but you know
I I thought you know maybe since you
know she might be my sister if she could
help me a little bit I've asked her a
couple times and she's always turned me
down said no no I'm not gonna help you
but to me I think the red flags about it
because it's like oh well are you gonna
keep the property up then since you're
not really helping I'm just very worried
about that if that makes sense I I would
I would come out of the gate and listen
just do what Ken said you're 21 years
old this is not the time of your life to
start divorcing yourself from your
innate wisdom this is the time to lean
into it and as a 21 year old you're
gonna have to practice it and these
lessons are going to pay dividends when
you're 30 40 and 50. but if your gut
says no
dude don't I don't make a rule that says
hey guys I just don't rent a family I
love you all too much and I want to make
sure that business doesn't mix with
family and by the way can I give you
some unsolicited advice
yeah of course if you're running around
as a 21 year old
um leveraging rental properties in Ohio
um you're going to be up for a world of
hurt
if you if you're buying these places
with cash cool but if you've watched a
lot of social media and you are trying
to
put seven percent down or no money down
or two percent down and you're buying a
rental house and you're gonna
immediately roll it into somebody else
I'm just telling you right now none of
my job would exist if my boss hadn't
done that exact same thing and gone
Stone broke when the when the economy
turned
I put 20 down on the Foreclosure I
bought about 70 000 and I've been fixing
up and spiral problems is this your only
home
uh yeah okay great so this is your
primary home can you move into it and
just have it be your house
um well I was gonna do it with I was
gonna live in an apartment my buddy so I
can live I can live for free because
well I'm charging it's hard I mean my
buddy split the rent for the apartment
and they should look for free in the
apartment if that makes sense I can save
up more money and pay off this house as
quickly as I can and buy my second
second house I I get the sentiment and
I'll just tell you personally as a guy
who's owned a bunch of houses yeah the
house I'm living in right now I told
this yesterday
um was thoroughly inspected and I got a
second inspection on a couple of other
issues and in the last 36 months I've
replaced a roof an air conditioner I've
got un thousands and thousands of
dollars in electrical repairs I got to
do so I'm telling you right now you're
living for free scam is not going to be
free I promise you that's just from a
guy that's owned a bunch of houses we
want you to live in that get the
roommate over there pay this sucker off
and now you've got your first property
and that's the way to do this oh I like
that roommate can can help you bring the
roommate over to the house there you go
and pay off the house early I like that
uh that that would be a great play for
you long term my friend again you're 21.
so anyway red flag listen to it on the
sister move forward without that I think
you're gonna be better off thank you
Brian for the call for the rest of you
don't move more of your calls coming up
he's John deloney I'm Ken Coleman this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
one guarantee and shipping is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Don Dr John deloney I
can't talk there's too many D the J the
whole thing threw me off there whatever
they are okay the medications could put
me on the board and as Don jaloney oh
did that that's how they did it man I
like that that's very good anyway he is
Dr John deloney I'm Ken Coleman welcome
to the show we're here to talk to you
about your life your money your work
your relationships by the way all three
of those issues are inextricably
connected if you're not winning in one
of them there's a good chance you might
be losing in the other we want to help
you today triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Carla is joining us now in Milwaukee
Wisconsin Carla how can we help
hey guys thank you so much I'm grateful
to be able to speak to you guys
um so my husband he took a promotion I
think he regrets taking it
um this coming early next year he will
be there 20 years
um and he has a pension so I know he's
sticking through it until then he's
super high anxiety I'm kind of very
worried about him and his Pals as we're
overall healthy people with how much
stress
um and so I'm just wondering how I can
be as supportive as possible how do I be
a supportive wife while I watch him go
through such negativity I'm trying to be
light and positivity
um sometimes it feels draining so I'm
just curious the best way I can go about
being as supportive tell us a little bit
yeah um
tell us a little bit more about this
recent promo how long ago was the
promotion he's been there 20 years how
long has he been in the new role
um about two years he did work with his
predecessor for a while and so with that
person being gone
um he's really taken on a lot of
responsibility all right that's my next
question is in that 20 years when did it
start to get as bad as it is now has it
been this way a while or is it connected
to this promotion
um it's connected to the promotion so he
did not have all this anxiety and all
this junk and all this negativity prior
to this
very perfectionist okay so he had the
anxiety making it worse okay that's what
I'm trying to figure out for John here
because I know you're ready to dive in
but so you're telling me the high
anxiety was already there uh but this
has made it way worse yes but he wasn't
miserable prior to this is what I'm
trying to get at was he was he miserable
um
miserable okay I'm just trying to get
the the levels of how it how this
particular promotion has changed things
because this plays into this yes
um all right John
I know you're ready to dig in on this
well it
so is he planning on being done in a
less than a year when his pension roll
uh becomes uh invested
um well that's kind of another question
I had is he's been doing this for so
long he doesn't know
what else he
Els he would after and so I'm trying to
do my best to kind of guide and give him
you know resources to figure out what
that could be we can help him with that
yes we can help him but this is a bigger
issue yeah you're now rolling over
you're becoming his mom you're not
because his wife
um right let me just tell you what
happened in my house it's the best I can
give you
um there came a moment when my wife
um
sat down with me and it wasn't a finger
in my face and it wasn't a yelling fight
it was not on the back heels of another
fight it was us just having some
connection time just talking
and she said I'm watching
um my husband die right in front of my
eyes and she said I don't like it I
don't know what to do about it but it's
hurting me and it's hurting you and it's
hurting the kid like and it was it was
not her just trying to like you said be
positive and be like hey it's gonna be
okay it was her acknowledging I see what
this is doing to you
and
um that for me was an impetus to I've
got to do some different things
and for me I stayed in the job I but I
had to have some boundaries here at work
I had to take care of my physical body
outside work I started exercising I had
to go see a counselor and deal with some
crap I hadn't dealt with in a long time
I had to go do a bunch of stuff I had to
get some different training on some
things and so
you can't be the person who is shoveling
all the stuff at your husband because
you're going to turn into his mom and
you're gonna make sure his socks are put
in the right drawer at the end of the
day
um but he does need you as somebody he
trusts and loves to also be a person who
can tell him the hard truth not about
what's wrong with him but about how this
is affecting you
so this the conversation is about you
um and you might feel like he doesn't
need one more thing he might finally be
at peace because somebody he loves sees
him for who he really is and that's a
guy who loves his family and a guy who's
out of gas
so that's what I was wondering so it's
not a selfish thing for me to
to how I feel about it it's a gift to
him it will be very hard to hear and he
might not have the tools to deal with it
on the back end
okay but you are here's the deal you're
keeping secrets from him
and he feels that disconnection and he's
trying to solve it and the only way he
knows how which is to go do more work
yeah our Communications really taken a
toll from all of this yes but we both
have recognized that it is something
we're working on but that's exactly how
it feels like a big city there is a
biological consequence to keeping
secrets at a marriage
it'll bear your marriage
and please don't use a fight as the
moment to dump a wheelbarrow full of
secrets on somebody set up a Saturday
morning we all gonna go to breakfast and
just have an open
we're a year out from you retiring I
need you to I need to tell you how I'm
experiencing the last couple of years
okay and I love you too much to not say
the truth
this is about how you feel not about
what he's doing you see you see the
difference
yes and Carla let me let me add to that
really quickly
um when you're saying this this is for
him you understand what I mean you're
concerned what John said is so powerful
the way your position is positioning
this but here's the thing he has to
understand and since we're not keeping
secrets anymore you can tell him that
that you called and I'd actually let him
watch this on YouTube That's The Power
of YouTube because I want to speak to
him for a second
there are two issues going on here there
is his anxiety John and the
perfectionism that she pointed out
that's coming from somewhere deeper and
then that's in your lane but that's him
and then there's his job and the common
denominator in both of those is him him
he has the choice he has the power to
get healing on the one issue the
perfectionism the anxiety all that stuff
but he also has the power to go you know
what this is not the best seat on the
bus for me and it's not worth gritting
and bearing it for one more year while
he's trying to get healthy in this case
what I'm saying is whatever's going on
with this particular seat on the bus it
has gotten worse and the seat isn't
helping whatever else is going on and I
just want you to somehow articulate that
car let it go to give him some
permission and some freedom to go I can
make these changes I should make these
changes and my wife is supportive of it
that's kind of what I I I want to make
that point John because absolutely then
he's going to feel less I hope defensive
and feel empowered to go oh I I can
actually make some choices we'll get to
the point of deciding what's next and
I'd love to give him the assessment the
get clear assessment and my book from
paycheck to purpose we'll give you those
as gifts Carl in just a moment but John
I wanted to bring it back to you on
there because that's what I'm hearing is
he needs to see that he's the common
denominator which means he can change
he's got to hear that he can change and
Carla can't say you have to do all of
this stuff that's right correct um and
so Carla a great gift my wife gave me
was she started going to a counselor
and she said I'd love for you to join me
and I because I'm a genius was like well
I already know all the answers to what
they're going to say that's what I do
for a living and so I put it off but she
kept going
and she kept going and then she'd come
home and then I started noticing a
different wife in an amazing way
and then I finally reached out to her
counselor and said hey would you see me
too
and I will tell you after the last six
months my whole life trajectory is
different and but it wasn't my wife
saying you got to go you got to go you
gotta go she was saying I love you so
much I wish you would and then she went
made an appointment for herself and I
got to watch her walk that path with a
light out into the distance and I got to
see it safe out there and then I headed
on myself
[Music]
you're a good lady Carla thank you so
much for trusting us and we're hoping
you and your husband I'd re-watch this
and talk through it together no secrets
here and there's no reason for anyone to
have any shame both of you are good
people that are navigating an uncertain
situation and you're going to come out
on the other side thank you again hey
don't move folks more of your calls
coming up here on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague Dr John
deloney and we are here for you America
taking your calls about your money your
relationships and your work already had
some really interesting calls combining
all three of those so if you're just
feeling stuck today you may be new to
the program you're going tired I don't
know if I trust these guys uh we would
love to earn your trust we want to help
you because there's a very clear path
forward despite what you feel right now
and we are here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
as I speak a brand new listener Sam
joins us from the great City of Austin
Texas Sam how can we help
hey uh John and Kane how are you we're
having a blast what's going on
hey I have a question for you I uh
recently was able to pay off all my debt
and um I'm already step three I have the
three to six months I'm getting ready to
move on step four nice invested 15 in
retirement
the only question I had would be would
it make sense to defer that and pay off
the home early
or if the 15 is a must
I'm kind of addicted to Bannon also yeah
man you're talking my language I get it
how close are you to paying the house
off
like if you went full bore how quickly
did you pay it off
about two and a half years and it would
be about four if I did the 15 give or
take
oh man you were right
do you have one job right now
yes I have one job and I also have a
pension how old are you
41. what's your income
uh so combine is about 260.
here's the deal man I know there's again
you you come with the the more correct
answer the more Global answer I can't
and good conscious tell you not to do
this if you are going to be any more
than two and a half years I would tell
you to Exhale and take a break
but if you tell me that at 43
you're gonna have your house paid off
and it's not going to kill it's not like
your wife's in on this y'all are all in
on this together
um and y'all are gonna Sprint for just
another 24 months another 30 months I
that's what I would do
let me be more clear that's exactly what
I did
I just paused it and ran if it's going
to be beyond that though what you don't
want to do is look up and be three five
seven ten years and you don't have any
retirement
but I did get so allergic to that debt
it made me insane what do you thinking
well you put me in a very interesting
situation here as you've decided to tell
someone to pause baby step four to go
into six I'll tell you what I know it's
not smart I'll tell you what what I we
believe in what we teach we teach the
steps in order and we're in four five
and six many times at the same time do
both of them what I would do is I would
continue investing the 15 but what I
would do is I would take that number so
in your head if you pause the 15 what
was that amount of money that would
allow you to change it from four years
to two what's the amount of money that
you would pull out of the 15 percent
so it would be about 36
000 a year okay so if we keep investing
at 15 then I would say if I want to
knock this out in two years I've got to
come up with an additional 36 000 on top
of you guys you guys have a great joint
income okay so I'm gonna say I'm gonna
keep paying the 15 but I've got in my
mind two and a half years or whatever it
is and I would say how do I come up with
thirty six thousand dollars more that's
a minimum to reach that goal you might
go well wait a second what if I could
come up with an additional fifty six
thousand through a second job selling
some stuff going crazy and now I pay it
off in a year and a half so we would
prefer that you pay the 15 off and then
find that if you're really want to knock
it out in two years come up with thirty
six thousand dollars in additional money
somebody of your ability in your
discipline I think you could do that so
I would ask you to consider that but I
understand what John is saying uh Ken is
right just just make no bones about it
well I'm following the Dave plant right
but I also understand what you're saying
and I don't think that you're wrong
that's why you I said you know what do
you want me to say you make a lot of
sense my friend you gave the right thing
I I reached a point where the debt made
me insane and when my wife well you are
already insane they just gave me magnify
the insanity that's right
um but yeah the the you don't want to
look up and have it been three four five
or you're almost there and then
something happens or you need a new boat
there in Austin because it's so
beautiful
um and then all of a sudden it turns
into three four and five years you look
up and you're 46 years old and you're
not investing
it makes most the most sense long term
for rational people to do exactly what
Ken just said
run the numbers
okay we gave you we gave you some common
sense advice we gave you an opinion in
in the middle of our baby steps but run
the numbers run the numbers with your
financial Pro you know and run the
numbers okay if I keep investing at 15
over the next four years run those
numbers so that you can see why we would
want you to continue to invest in that
time and the difference between two
years of paying off the house uh I think
if you run those alternate numbers of
not investing I think that's a good
exercise for you because I do think and
John John I think is nailed this year
this is an emotional question and you're
a dude who's very disciplined and you're
crushing it but you're just so mad at
the debt and so we want you to pull back
from that while it's a good emotion
towards that debt long term I think you
come out better investing for four years
and having a paid off house the the
numbers won't lie but I want you to see
that on your own does that make sense
yeah I don't want to miss out on that
opportunity costs about 15 minutes well
said you said it better than I said you
give yourself good advice so appreciate
the call my friend that's awesome let's
go to Jenny in Salt Lake City Jenny how
can we help
hey thanks for taking my call
um I have a question kind of similar to
the one before
um my husband and I were trying to
decide if we should sell our rental
property
um we don't have any debt besides our
first mortgage and then we bought this
rental property in April 2020 so right
after covid
um we bought it for a hundred thousand
we put it on a 15-year at three and a
half percent
um and it's it's two hours away so it's
not convenient to like if my husband has
to do something on it but we bought it
because it was
cheap like for for where we live
um and so we're looking at it now and I
had this whole plan that we could pay it
off in the next year and a half but then
my husband started thinking that maybe
we should just sell it
um and then we can put that towards our
mortgage so that our first mortgage so
that we can get that paid off a lot
sooner so why does he want to sell it
you had this good plan it's very doable
but he came and came at it went nah I
think I'm done with it I want to know
why he's done with it
so like I said it's two hours away and
the reason why it was cheaper because
here in Salt Lake it's quite expensive
for any any type of house so it's not in
the best city
um and so we've had a big turnaround in
tenants and we've been we've always had
a duplex ourselves that we had lived in
so we've been landlords for over 15
years but this is a turnaround of every
six months this is a pain in the you
know what that's what this is he's done
with it so if we sell it today how much
do you walk away with
so we could walk away between 225 and
250. good good so that's what it's
asking for so and we only owe under 80
000. okay okay so so you're gonna get
two to two fifty you owe 80 on it and
then how much do you owe on your primary
home
so we owe
260. I'd sell this tonight no break I'd
have a sign in the yard now no brainer
because number one it's already a pain
neither one of you you're trying to
justify keeping it it's a pain and it
changes your life in two ways it removes
the pain
and then it it makes the profit on
having a cash house you're gonna pay
that house off quickly
my goodness this is a no-brainer Jenny
he feels like you're the one trying to
talk yourself into this
I well it's just like
like the 500. It doesn't matter your
cash flow is going to be massive when
you don't have a mortgage on your
primary home talk about that cash flow
and your husband maybe doesn't want to
do real estate anymore yeah you don't
need to have that conversation because
it sounds like he doesn't want to be a
landlord anymore the turnover you could
hear it the turnover every six months
it's two hours away it's not a dream
property gone done bye yeah bye Felicia
I love that oh don't move more of your
calls they're stacked up they're lined
up like planes awaiting to land we're
gonna get to all of them don't move this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney joins me this
hour as we take your calls Triple eight
eight two five five two two five hey are
you struggling big time in a
relationship situation how about a work
situation maybe some toxicity John and I
love to do those calls together it's got
a unique vantage point from our areas
especially he's in the relationship and
mental health area I'm in the workspace
we talk about your money as well so that
is the opportunity today triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go back to the phones Alex is joining us
in Erie Pennsylvania Alex how can we
help
hello uh how's everyone afternoon June
we're having a blast how are you doing
I'm doing okay all right my question is
uh I have I've been on the baby step one
just got it done and I've been kind of
on baby step two for a while paying off
my credit cards and I'm stuck with the
decision between paying off my student
loans or a car that I had to purchase
yeah can you hold still hold that phone
still see if we can get you a little bit
better all right so say it again
between your house
in your car
yeah my student loans is about twenty
thousand and my car is also about twenty
thousand
and what did you say you have credit
card as well
well that's all paid off I just got it
paid off okay last month okay so the
only debt you have are the twenty
thousand dollar student loan or twenty
thousand dollar car
correct and what's your question
well the question is what
I I'm just able to start paying them off
but the interest rates on them are just
crazy on my car it's seven percent okay
but my student loans are two thousand
four thousand well two percent and four
percent and
in the baby steps they always want you
to start with the lowest amount which is
stuck with
which would technically be the student
loans by like a thousand dollars
but
if I don't if I keep paying off my
student loans I'll in the long run pay
more off of my car
sure I'll have to pay more for the car
duty that's like seven percent interest
rate are your student loans consolidated
are they in six or seven different
smaller loans all lumped together
they're in separate smaller loans a few
of them are like three percent and a few
are four percent yeah I don't I I I know
it weighs on you I I personally whenever
I was going through this process don't
care about the
interest rates well we have found time
and time again for decades now is the
psychology of little wins is what keeps
people running
and so if you're taking multiple loans
five or six or seven different loans and
you are one's two thousand one's four
thousand one six thousand they all add
up to twenty and then you look over and
you have a car loan for twenty one
thousand I would line up those those
loans smallest to largest and knock each
one of them out over and over and over
and over again you're going to be
surprised at how much the hundred and
fifty dollars here the 300 here the 250
dollars here when you're ready to start
paying off your car and that's the last
debt you have and all those payments are
rolling towards that one thing it will
go quicker than you think it will yeah
and let's take a look at the car let's
take a look at this car how much is it
worth
the car is worth about twenty three
thousand all right and you feel like you
can get 23 on the open market with it if
you've done the the Kelly Blue Book and
you got that number pretty correct
yeah all right the car is relatively new
I had to get a car pretty quickly and
because my parents had to co-sign
regardless of practically anywhere I
would have looked they would not let me
get a used car
is it your money or mom and dad's money
it was my money that that I saved those
under their account so well I get it but
we need to clean up this car so I
changed my mind I would sell that car
private Market too and then how much
cash do you have on hand
not that much okay but here's the deal
you need to sell this car and you get a
you get a three thousand dollar car and
trust me you can get a three thousand
dollar car that'll get from A to B and
Mom and Dad don't get a say in it
because you need to pay your mom and dad
back or get them off this thing either
this loan out of your life and how much
is your car payment a month I'm gonna
give you some real numbers here what's
your car payment uh my car payment is
450. dude you just got a 450 raise
now that 450 dollars right there goes
into these student loans you're knocking
out those student loans pretty quickly
if you work a second job or third job
you're a young guy you're able you can
go make 15 20 25 an hour in some labor
positions and you're knocking this out
just like John said and then we can
upgrade on the car but right now we're
gonna get rid of this stuff and get rid
of it quick how old are you brother
uh 22. all right so I'm gonna tell you
something it took me a long time to
learn
I I have some of the best parents on
planet Earth I love my mom and my dad
they're both still alive they're both
still married they're both very very
wise and they are a gift
and they do not get a vote into how I
spend my money
how I raise my kids what I do with my
career
the earlier you can adopt the
understanding that your mom and dad do
not get a vote into your adult life they
can give you wisdom they can walk
alongside you it's their job to give you
opinions on everything that's what Mom
and dads are supposed to do
it's your job as an adult to internalize
you don't get a vote
unless I specifically ask Hey Dad how do
I how would you handle this situation or
hey Mom how would you handle the
situation and I do do that
but bro your mom and dad don't get a
vote on what kind of car you have to
drive
and that's a recipe for being broke you
bought a car that you cannot afford
and they put you in that position don't
do that sell the car man and you're
gonna get a car that nobody's gonna date
you over so what man so what
all right we just hit you with a lot
where's your head at on this
so
I I did have a pretty beat up car before
that but
my reasoning for getting the new car was
it was reliable and and for my job I I
have to at least
have a presentable car
because I'm I am something that's
reliable what's your job you need a lot
of Maintenance uh I work
at a company that in my apartment that
is really strict on cars
and on what's in the you work for a
company in your apartment
yeah I don't even understand what that
means
so they have like policies on hey if you
have a beat up car
uh it it's a term for you know I would
dare a company to fire you I don't even
understand what you're saying because
can you park around the corner they
don't want to beat up old car in the
parking lot is that what you're saying
yeah dude yeah nonsense I'd park in the
front row I would park it in the front
room to the hood but even that even if
that's the issue quit your job good gosh
dude pull around the corner yeah I mean
bro listen we just laid it out for you
you don't want to sell your car and
that's fine you can be in debt for
another couple years you can knock your
lights out
um we'll send you here's what I'm doing
I'm gonna send you FPU for free
Financial Peace University I want you to
go through it but you gotta promise dude
you're gonna have to watch all the
lessons and actually sit down and
internalize this stuff because you
clearly didn't get this from home
but you're gonna have to learn this
stuff we're not telling you to sell your
car because we don't like your car we're
not telling you just not sell your car
we don't want you to have fun we're
telling you to sell your car because we
want you to be free yeah
yeah and we want you to stop having to
go to Mommy and Daddy to cosign alone as
an adult and I don't want you working at
a place that doesn't want you there
because of the status of your car that's
Insanity I'm not
I I I'm gonna I choose to believe Alex
someone has told him that but there's
all kinds of violations uh on that I
gotta believe there's some HR red flags
if you if a company were saying you
can't drive that car in the parking lot
I I I'm assuming in a right to work
state they can do whatever they want to
but I can fire you for whatever they
want which sounds I don't know but if
that was me and that was really the case
I'm pulling the car uh around the corner
and I'll walk a half a mile I'm not
gonna take out a twenty thousand dollar
loan to keep an entry-level job 450 a
month my friend that's what we're
telling you to get rid of and think
about how the 450 a month pays off the
rest of those loans that's what we want
you to consider but you do you man
appreciate the call I want to thank Dr
John deloney for hanging out with me
this hour James Childs our fearless
leader and the crew behind the glass to
keep us on the air and you America thank
you this is your show this is the Ramsay
show
Ken Coleman here did you know the Ramsay
show is one of the most popular podcasts
in the world it's your daily dose of
advice on life and money check out all
of our shows from the Ramsay Network
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
your relationships and your work the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Dr John deloney that's
twice in a row I can't get the doctor
and the John today I'm just gonna go
John the rest of the show it works for
me and no way to slight your hard work
oh I have two phdslighted okay just call
me Jose I don't know what's happening
this guy from the parking lot James I
can't say doctor and John at the same
time so we'll just keep on moving with
that you're becoming the doctor doctor I
haven't been called doctor I like that
that's actually great that's a term of
endearment the guys in the class don't
like it we're in charge they are not
we're on the mic until they cut it off
that's how that works Katrine is up next
in Charlotte North Carolina Katrina how
can we help
hi thank you for taking the call you bet
what's up
so I uh just started FPU this week
actually I'm on baby step number one
um I've out of the thousand dollars I
just have 25 and I'm getting paid on uh
tomorrow so I'm going to be able to add
a lot more to it however I actually uh
know that I need to make more money
um once I learned everything about the
Dave Ramsey uh Finance financial piece
uh my 35 annual income it's low so I
learned I need to make more money so I
applied to some jobs and I actually got
interviews and potential offers in
another state so is it a good idea to
move if I'm just on baby step number one
well I wouldn't let baby step one be the
determined uh determinate Factor here
for instance uh if you get a if you get
a raise and you are doing work that you
really enjoy work that you're good at
for a company that there's some
alignment there and this is just an
overall great decision
then you moving uh in baby step one two
three or four really doesn't matter as
long as you can afford the move so if
you gotta go bust it a little bit let's
say your move cost you a couple thousand
or or three thousand or five thousand or
whatever it is whatever that move cost
is you've got to fund that
um and so that has to be obviously a
part of the conversation but I wouldn't
turn down a great opportunity that you
knew was a great opportunity just
because you're in baby step one does
that make sense okay yes so do so I mean
I guess I've been doing this for like
four days do I is this is I just pause
now and just save up as much money to
move I'd wait until I had an opportunity
yeah let's wait until we have a deal on
the table
because here's the deal some companies
will pay certain amount of money towards
moving expenses so let's just say I'm
making this up let's say it's costing
you four thousand dollars to move I'm
making that up I have no idea what the
move will cost and the company gives you
2500 towards that now you know okay I've
got to come up with fifteen hundred
dollars to afford this move what we
don't want you to do is go backwards we
don't want you to use a credit card for
this we want you to get really creative
very aggressive to be able to pay for
the move but if we're moving to a better
situation it allows us to get through
the baby steps faster
can I throw one thing at you Katrina
yeah absolutely
if you let's say you got a job two
states over okay and it was exciting and
they were gonna they're gonna pay you
fifty thousand instead of 35 it was
gonna be a job you were excited about
I want you to look very carefully at the
things in your home that you think you
have to move
the number of times I had a Craigslist
couch that I ended up paying more money
to move than the stupid couch was even
worth or I would store it that's good
listen both me and Jade were talking
yesterday Jade warshaw were talking
about how we have had outdoor furniture
inside our homes for years because
that's all we could afford and yeah it
was
shockingly fine everybody lived and so
if you have a bunch of incredible Deluxe
bajillion dollar couches and whatever
you got to move fine if you are like me
when I was making 35 Grand figuring out
oh I need to do something different
leave all that stuff give it away put it
on the curb and give it away and that
will drastically reduce your move cost
you need a mattress and you can build up
from there yeah I love that advice I
love it you can okay listen not only are
you reducing your cost you can pay for
the move by selling those things that
you don't need
so I love that advice so Katrina head up
don't don't quit the baby steps this is
going to help you advance through the
baby steps you got it I yeah I wasn't
even this part gives me a lot of clarity
because there was a part of me that was
like I'm committing to this whole new
Financial thing and then now I'm getting
interviews I've gone for this month and
the pay uh right now I get paid eight
17.50 and the increase goes up from 25
to 28 an hour so I know this is a
blessing and I don't want to turn it
down but I just felt like I was
backtracking like I decided this and
then now I'm doing bad and I felt a
little bit no it's the opposite you got
on a plan and the universe opened up a
path for you you didn't even know
existed
moved
from where we had established families
where we lived to a new city for a new
position and it's transformed Our Lives
yeah
okay okay so this is
the night shouldn't be so fast don't be
fearful at all you just you're gonna
make more money and and here's the deal
though let me caution you on this I want
to because I I'm the work guy I gotta
say this please don't just look at these
opportunities as just a bigger paycheck
the world is full of millions of people
that change jobs over the last two years
John they call it the great regret who
they took a bigger paycheck but they got
there and they realized I like those
people back there or I like the position
back there a little bit more so what I'm
saying is don't just take it for the
extra money I want you to make sure that
the position itself again is a good fit
for you you can do the work you've got
the skill and you enjoy it enough or it
is a I can do it I think it's a good
culture good environment
and this is a ladder for me if I do a
good job for two years I can see myself
climbing a ladder and getting to where I
ultimately want to be I don't want you
just making the decision just for the
paycheck okay
okay I'd hate to see you approach your
life I'll write all this yeah absolutely
absolutely so proud of Youth Welcome to
our crazy little gang that you just
joined we're excited to have you I love
that that is so great John what's the uh
what's psychology going on there I think
that's a really interesting question I
think there's a lot of new people that
are joining our show every day we see
the numbers and people are watching
people listening and she's just started
and she went wait a second I have to
choose one or the other I got to do the
baby steps and get out of debt or I got
to choose to take a job there's
something there was a fear there that we
just kind of helped her with what was it
well it's it's this strange phenomenon
and I'm certain there's a psychological
term that I probably took in a class A
decade ago I forgot the term but
it happens a lot with people talking
about we need to move everything to
crypto because it's all coming down or
I've got to move all my money into
silver gold because it's all coming down
the illusion there is when it all comes
down
I'm gonna need a way to put gas in my
car so I can get to my job not realizing
if it all comes down your job is gone
right some similarly on the flip side
when we enter into Financial Peace we
enter into a new plan a new relationship
we think that our life is going to be
exactly the same with just this new
thing and we don't have a psychology for
oh no no sometimes when you change your
life everything changes and it feels
scary on the front end but it's
incredible love that so proud of you
Katrina we're rooting for you can't wait
to hear the great news and we'd love to
hear you call back to your debt free
scream this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague John
deloney we're thrilled that you are with
us triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five Boston
Massachusetts is where we go next Mel is
there Mel how can we help
hello thank you for taking my calls you
bet
uh you know I just have a quick question
with you know I just I'm just into that
and I just feel like at the end of the
mom at the end of paying everything I
just have no money for myself and you
know I'm slowly paying it off and doing
OT it's not like I'm just doing my 40
and going home it's just kind of like
I'm putting in you know 32 hours of op
out of two weeks I feel like I never
have enough money
okay how do you know if you I give you
some advice or some help sure well let's
first start with asking you what's your
what's your budgeting process like do
you budget at all
yes I actually did start last month um I
took the whole month of June to kind of
just see what I spend my money on and
I've noticed I spent a lot of money on
food like just eating out and
um one good side about that of doing
that is now I know I spend it on that so
now I'm not being more conscious about
it do so you've only done this one month
so let me start by saying
we've told people for decades takes
about 90 days three months or so to just
figure this thing out so give yourself
some Grace as you're heading into month
two but what you're focusing on is how
much am I short do you have an idea how
short you are right now at the end of
the month
well usually I'm never really sure it's
just kind of like at the end I was kind
of just like I'll have like two three
four hundred dollars so like for myself
because I spend on whatever I want now
usually just end up putting that in a
savings and then kind of just like
living what like two hundred dollars
so what do you know after your first
month of budgeting that where there's a
lot of fat that you can trim off we've
already identified one which is eating
out what else where else are you
spending a lot of money that you don't
need to spend it
um probably going out as well is this
food like food eating out at work trying
to find some food and then going out
like on the weekend all right what's the
combined number that you spent last
month just ballpark figure on going out
uh and eating out
um from probably about
uh let's see
probably last month about like six seven
hundred dollars all right so there's a
six to seven hundred dollar difference
right there if you begin to cut that you
get disciplined you understand what I'm
saying so now you want to cut back for a
month in month number two of budgeting
and then look for other expenses that
you can cut and go okay can I find and
I'm just making this up right now but
you've got it could I find an additional
thousand dollars a month right now do
you have any debt
I do so I mean it's kind of weird so
um about a year ago actually a year ago
back in a couple of days I broke my
ankle and I was working as a manager of
security and then they laid me off the
contract ended so they wanted to give me
another job that was very relaxing
payment you know offering in the teams
when I was getting up to close the 30s
so I you know decided just to take some
time off and
find a new job that wasn't security I
found a new job and then I broke my
ankle again I was probably out of work
for about six seven months and then in
that time I amassed about you know
twelve thousand dollars in debt and then
another like two thousand dollars in
credit card debt so and you Consolidated
the twelve thousand
okay so the only debt you have is twelve
thousand dollars it's been Consolidated
recently is that what I'm hearing yes
and what's that yeah twelve thousand
dollars in a consolidated loan about two
thousand dollars in credit card and then
I have a mortgage
okay so you're familiar with our baby
steps yes
yeah okay so where are you on the I know
you're trying to budget and the
budgeting is a learning process while
we're attacking the debt so do you have
a thousand dollars in your emergency
fund
baby step one
uh yeah well tell me when tomorrow I get
paid so I know I've done so this you
know last week I did about 35 hours of
overtime so I can just pay off the
here's my credit card here's my you're
not answering my question my friend baby
step one is one thousand dollars in a
savings account for an emergency do you
have that right now
yes you have a thousand dollars
yes in savings
yes not more just a thousand
yes I have a thousand dollars in my
savings account I gotta have my regular
checkings account okay so the baby steps
now you've got baby step one done now
we're taking the smallest debt you have
and we're gonna attack that with
everything you have the budgeting
process that we just walked through is
to find as much money as possible that
you can attack the debt snowball with so
the smallest debt is what you're going
after next and then if you knock when
you knock that out you take what you
have been paying towards that and you
put it towards the next one and you just
keep working through this process do you
understand what I'm saying
yeah that's what's next for you
I okay what do you do for a living man
well I'm a ranger at the moment no I
work for um Commonwealth
a ranger is that a park ranger or a
police officer yeah
park ranger okay
um do you live on site do you live on at
a camp or do you live at home
no I live at home it's about 15 minutes
away so I take the public transportation
I don't own a car uh that's good news
okay uh I was gonna suggest you uh pick
up a second and third job
um and begin figuring out ways but
you're working overtime so much here's
what I think you got to do man you gotta
you got to get radical
the way Dave says it is I will not see
the inside of a restaurant unless I work
at one
I will not go on a date with somebody
unless we are going for a walk in a
beautiful Oregon Park
I'm just not going to spend any money
because I gotta get out from under this
debt
so I can get my life back you don't have
a life right now man you're killing
yourself working overtime just to stay
afloat
all right and we we say it all the time
and you're just worth more of a life
than the one you're leading and so man
keep working overtime but get this stuff
out you don't have a huge amount of debt
um you do live in a state that takes a
big chunk of your paycheck every time
you bring some home so that'll take a
little bit longer than it might in
another state but man I would just keep
hammering it and hammering it and
hammering it and get it get it done
right because I know I mean like I said
I worked a whole bunch of overtime in
the credit card debt by tomorrow when I
get paid it's going to be done so then
the consolidated loan is what's next
it's awesome right so so how quickly can
you pay off that twelve thousand if if
you give it everything you got by
cutting all of your expenses
that you can cut I mean you cut
everything that you don't need how
quickly could you pay off the 12 000.
I mean you know I did some math around
it and I think I can get it down
hopefully you know with
with the projected number I have about
probably next summer great no chance you
can get it done faster than that I
absolutely agree but you're gonna have
to work you have to work more so I don't
know if you're if you're changing jobs
you're talking about a year from now you
you how much do you make
I make about 50 000 for my job and then
I have a income home so I have events at
home that I make about an extra 900 a
month
I would sell that rental home you can't
afford it
can you sell that home well the mortgage
is paid and I actually make money from
it oh so you own that Home Free and
Clear
no so I have a mortgage on it but with
the amount of money I get from it the I
pay the mortgage plus I get um in it
towards me what you can't afford it what
do you do tomorrow if the air
conditioner goes out how are you gonna
pay for that
that's you know that is where when I
broke my ankle that was where one of the
reasons I had mastered a lot of that no
we're running out of time running out of
time I got to be quick sorry to
interrupt but it's on purpose how much
is that house worth right now if you
sold it today
about 360. what do you owe on it
about 2 30. sell that house today you're
debt free of a fully funded emergency
fund and you are starting to pay off
your mortgage brother you know what
you'll do on Monday of next week sleep
deeper than you slept in years
you still haven't recovered
psychologically from breaking your ankle
and you're gonna have to forgive
yourself for the seven months where it
was really tough to get up and move
around after that and you just didn't
work and you stayed at home and you dug
yourself a hole let's clear that hole
you're on the right path now brother
you're on the right path stay on the
line I'm going to send you Financial
Peace University and every dollar app
the best app for taking care of your
daily and monthly budget stand alone I'm
gonna give it to you as my gift to send
you onto the right path sell that house
brother and get free Mel you got this
ramseysolutions.com find a great real
estate Pro there and get that house
listed and change your life forever
great stuff this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman Dr John deloney joins me
this hour triple eight eight two five
5225 is the number if you're new to the
show we have a lot of you that are
joining us every day and we're so
excited that you're here if you want to
dive deeper into this what is this
Ramsay baby steps what is this about how
do I
I get out of debt what is this process
we want you to go to ramseysolutions.com
and click on the get started button
that's ramseysolutions.com and click on
get started and it'll catch you up on
everything that we talk about where you
are in the journey so that you get
caught up and uh if you're enjoying the
show a couple things I want you to know
about please consider whether you're
watching or listening subscribing
sharing leaving a review that would be
great and uh this is exciting you can
now watch the Ramsey show as a live
stream on Twitter that's twitter.com
ramsayshow twitter.com ramsayshow I
would have never thought all those years
ago when Twitter came out that one day
we would be live streaming on Twitter
this is exciting John I'm gonna let you
take over I need to call my mom real
quick she's going to be very proud it's
gonna be a great moment hey Mom I'm live
streaming on Twitter No I kid if only I
knew even how to I don't know how to do
it either I had to ask James where do
you even see it uh so there you go it's
uh twitter.com
show right there at the top of the feed
apparently everybody's streaming on
Twitter you and me right now pal we
don't even know how to do it but we're
there we are there doesn't that make you
feel super important it does me all
right all my dreams are coming true
we'll celebrate on the commercial break
I can only imagine there it is his
favorite song folks let's go to Alberta
Canada Annika is joining us there Annika
how can we help
hey um I just have a question for you
about kind of starting my financial
Journey independently
um I'm a mom of two and I I separated
from my husband over Christmas last year
and I just finished school
um an education degree and I have a
contract starting in September and you
know some money in the bank so I'm just
kind of wondering
yeah how I should start independently
I'm kind of scared and nervous about it
well have you sat down and done a budget
yet on what this contract is going to
provide you versus how much gonna it's
gonna cost to live in the area of the
school
yeah
um so I should be making net
um six thousand dollars a month and I've
budgeted
um I've actually just got a rental a few
weeks ago and it's 1650
um so I've gone through the every dollar
app and budgeted all my expenses
what's your gross take home
um it's 64 a year and then I get child
support at three grand a month okay
there you go okay
um so what makes you nervous it sounds
like you're making plenty of money and
you've got the tools you're using them
um what makes you what makes you nervous
I think just going from uh like being in
a relationship where my spouse was
making a ton of money and I haven't been
in control of our finances at all for
the last eight years
um basically just living off of
an allowance and then you know so taking
Independence I guess of it and uh
I don't want to make a misstep
so let me go ahead and clear you of that
worry you will
you'll make a bunch of them that's
because you're human
just like me Ken everybody even James
back in the booth makes mistakes way
more than you would think
um I said part of this is part of being
human right and so give yourself some
Grace there you're learning a new set of
skills and the fear is real how much of
this are you looking at the numbers and
realizing just how much your life is
going to change your lifestyle is going
to change
so much I'm moving from you know like a
big beautiful five-bedroom house to a
duplex rental
um you know and not only that but just
lifestyle changes with being able to go
out and eat and all the things yeah
this is something that um gets left out
of the conversation but you're gonna
have to grieve this transition
you're gonna have to spend some time
telling a friend sitting with a
counselor sitting with yourself and I
wish I had a better word that didn't
sound so woo-woo and pilates yoga but
you're gonna have to journal about you
have to write it down
I'm frustrated that
this relationship didn't work out I was
in an abusive situation I was given an
allowance I wasn't even a full person
um I'm gonna miss not worrying about
money I'm gonna miss all these things
and here's what I get to do you gotta
spend some time in that ugliness if you
just try to avoid it your body's gonna
try to solve for it man and it's gonna
you're gonna feel anxious all the time
you're gonna feel like you're always
missing out you're never gonna settle
into your new reality
mm-hmm
I just it's scary you know maybe a
single mom is is yeah it's like riding a
bike you remember when you rode a bike
for the first time you were equal parts
terrified but also excited to figure it
out
yeah that's what's going on and I think
it's very important to I hope you're
really uh Embrace what John told you
you're gonna make some mistakes just
like you did riding the bike uh but the
fact that you're getting involved here
with the baby steps and financial peace
and you're pursuing this when you skin
your knee it's gonna be okay it's gonna
heal you're going to be fine you're
gonna figure out how to budget all these
things you're going to learn how to eat
differently than you did and it's gonna
stink and you're gonna look back on some
things but at the same time you're gonna
go you know what this is only for a
season it's going to keep getting better
and so that's what I want you to hear is
that you're gonna be fine and I would
channel that excitement about being
independent about a fresh start
you got this we're gonna walk with you
yeah so here's the deal I want you to
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of my book on your past change your
future and the whole premise of the book
is
so everything's in Ash and that scary
terrifying question what am I gonna do
now
and there's no path for that there's no
there's that's not in our public lexicon
because the the way our culture talks
about it is either somebody's got to
rescue you or you just gotta suck it up
and grind it out and crush it and kill
nonsense the book lays out a path for
you to move out of what I hoped would
happen versus what actually is and what
do we do next okay so hang on the line
here we're going to send you a copy of
that thing you've got this it's going to
be wobbly it's going to be a struggle
it's going to be a challenge the one
thing Ken and I would tell you
is to make sure you've got some friends
in your life some people around you that
will walk alongside you and help pick
you up when you fall and scrape your
knee which you're gonna do it's really
true you know that's true in any
transition of life where there's just a
lot of uncertainty sometimes it's just
nice to be in a place with people that
you can be vulnerable with and go I
don't know how I'm going to get through
tomorrow yeah and then they go you're
fine I know what I'm in my most pathetic
and I'm around the right people they
look at that pathetic voice and
empathetic posture or whatever I'm
saying and they just in a loving way go
uh snap out of it you know like you're
gonna be okay and you need that you
gotta have that yeah and um you also
have to have people and this is gonna
make us not popular on the Twitter
sphere oh boy
um we just started live streaming it'd
be nice already you're gonna get in
trouble all right you need some people
let me say it this way it's okay to be
sad if you wreck your Lexus yeah it's
okay and in a culture our culture is oh
yeah oh yeah it must be nice now it
sucks and it sucks if you have a life
where you have a really nice home and
you're married to somebody who's making
a great salary and then you separate
from that and you're a single parent and
you are lamenting on what was you're
allowed to do that in fact we're going
to sit with you because it's a it's a
bummer yes millions of people don't have
that that doesn't mean it doesn't hurt
right and if you skip over and try to
pretend like oh it's fine get everybody
then your body's gonna continue and
continue and continue to try to solve
for it so no matter where you are on the
pecking order whether you are struggling
to find groceries or whether you used to
have all the money in the world and now
suddenly you don't you gotta sit in that
reality and grieve it man yeah as you
transition I thought she said something
that I I found it to be heroic given her
situation and not being able to even
understand what she's dealing with but
she said I'm a little bit excited about
yeah I'm kind of excited about being
independent I think she's actually in a
really good place given she's been
through a lot right now she's just
nervous about it yeah and she did what
is why she reached out to a couple of
Knuckleheads and said hey am I crazy am
I and we said no no you're good to go
yeah and you've got to be fine but I
never will bet John against a mama bear
I'm not betting it's a single mom I
don't care how many mistakes she makes
never so I I feel real good all our
chips are in on you Annika hang on the
line we'll get you John's book you're on
your way to a better future thanks again
for trusting us and for the call this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
the Ramsey Show continues we're thrilled
that you're with us I'm Ken Coleman Dr
John deloney joins me in studio this
hour taking your calls about your money
your relationships your work triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to Clint in moppin Oregon Clint
how can we help
yeah hi Clint
hey how's it going thank you guys for
your time you bet what's up
so
um I've got a lot of different ways that
I could I want to make changes in my
life
and I've got a lot of different ways
that I could go so I started a
construction company about two years ago
and
um since then I had three employees and
kind of come to the point where I don't
have any more
I've also picked up a second job as an
independent sales rep with that I picked
up quite a bit of debt in equipment and
trucks and from credit card
and so I'm wondering right now I've kind
of found that I'm I'm not the best
businessman that I thought I love
construction and I love building but
it just ended up I live in a small
community and I seem to always create a
friendship rather than a business
relationship so
part of me wants to quit the
construction and just get rid of the
debt but I have a lot of people that are
telling me that I'm not really that far
into that and you know the situation
that I'm in is not that bad and I do I I
do make all my bills and stuff but
I listen to your guys's show just
recently started and uh it I mean I used
to be debt-free before I started the
company and so now I'm kind of like
looking at my situation and looking at
how I feel at the end of the day let me
ask you a question real quick let me ask
you something when you say you're you
turn you're more of a friendship than
business does that mean that you're
doing work for people and you're having
a hard time charging what does that mean
yeah pretty much so I I worked at the
store here
um we're a really small uh area so
um worked at the only store in town
and I just ended up like being there
getting a relationship with everybody
um in the town and so now it's like I
started a company and they all want to
support me but I feel uh myself I just
yeah okay so were you doing renovations
what kind of construction work were you
doing
so I did everything I mean my major
background is an excavation that's why I
ended up buying the excavator in the
pickup
um
both were situational uh I had a paid
for truck but it was being pushed way
too hard it was not really built for
what it was doing okay so I just
continued to break it
um at the time it was post covered and
uh the market for used trucks was just
you couldn't find them and so so clever
you guys talk a lot about telling people
to get rid of their cars um but mine is
is a tool not like a life yeah let me
let me let me dive back in because I
want to get a picture of where you are
on this so we can give you some advice
on this so are were people disputing
your hourly rate when you were quoting
them or were you just knowingly uh short
selling yourself essentially by not
quoting because you feel bad about it
you didn't want to face rejection John
can figure that out for you he's
probably got a beat on it but I just
want to understand you've lost these
employees it's down to you now and
you're trying to decide do I stay with
this and pay off this debt and and learn
how to be a better businessman by maybe
just me and me trying to help you here
but I need to understand why weren't you
making enough money is it because you
didn't charge enough or people said you
charge too much what's going on
no I I just never I in fact I made a
list from last year of the job that I
did for free just because so I grew up
in a pretty Christian background and so
I don't know I used to help all kinds of
people just because I enjoyed building
and it wasn't how I made a living but
now that's kind of carried on and is
that why you couldn't pay your people
no no I didn't lose my employees because
of money they they just found other jobs
okay there was no I didn't lose them
Inspire them they just they found better
how much debt do you have for the
company
for the company I'm about 154 000. okay
what's your debt service on that what do
you have to pay every month
um it's it's hard to say I saw like 18
000 in credit cards uh the truck's like
71 excavator 69. and the interest rates
will vary from uh like almost nothing
yeah you know how much money you have to
make every month just to just to break
even with your debt payments what is
that number
8 000 and that includes like my living
my house and stuff
so you've got to make a minimum of eight
thousand to keep your home lights on and
your business lights on
yeah have you ever cleared that
yeah oh yeah okay so there's plenty of
work in moppin so there's plenty of
opportunity and you've cleared eight
thousand dollars or more before
definitely all right so what are you
questioning whether or not you should
stay with this why are you questioning
or let me ask you this did you get into
it and you're a year and a half into it
and this just isn't the job for you
so here's here's what happened I at this
winner I ended up so I used to manage
the hardware store here and so that one
of the companies actually reached out to
me that I used to work with
and so I started working for them as a
sales rep an independent sales rep so I
don't have hours and I'm able to flex my
time around so I'm doing both are you
making good money doing sales do you
like that more than being a construction
manager
well it it's making like I mean I'll
probably get like a 8 500 check so I'm
looking at that and how much time I
spent and then I look at like that's not
the answer I'm trying to decide if I
should keep both Clint you didn't answer
John's question answer this question
do you like the sales role more than you
do doing construction work
we're talking about enjoy one more than
the other I do enjoy both of them okay
um I think I'm just frustrated with the
one right now sure I would be too if
you're clearing as much money as you say
you are in the in the construction even
the way you answer that like have you
cleared eight thousand oh yeah
then you could make a plan and be
completely debt free and own all these
trucks in one calendar year
if you actually said to yourself I'm
gonna honor these people by charging
them a wage so that I don't have to
worry about money and I am going to be
able to be in the best position to do
the best possible work for them I had a
counseling Professor once that gave us
all a great talking to and she said if
you're a therapist and you can't eat
you're worried about paying your bills
because you undercharge everybody you
cannot be a good therapist for the
clients who show up to you needing your
full self so you have to charge a living
wage you have to charge what you're
worth and so you can't shortchange your
customers you can't shortchange yourself
now if you don't like doing that part
then get out of the business
but it doesn't sound like that at all it
sounds like there's one part of it that
you don't like and that's the making
money part of it the telling them hey
here's how much my business costs being
told hey we can't afford that right now
great it's awesome I will be here when
you're ready be fantastic and
so be it man but also if you like both
jobs and you're able to take care of
your home responsibilities knock your
lights out I I I'm confused as to what
your ultimately what your question is
because it sounds like things are going
fine either way you just have a whole
bunch of debt and you can't breathe and
yeah you're right I wouldn't do that but
what's that what's the challenge
I guess it's just
uh
I think it's just might be a long I I
guess maybe honestly I was looking for a
way out because I always hear you guys
say about like dumping your debt but my
debt technically makes money and so I
don't care about that I don't care about
that I think he wants out I think he won
out of the business sell your stuff dude
sell it
sell it all and pay off the last truck
and just do home remodels out of your
truck yeah yeah that's true if you want
it if you got the itch for that didn't
do that but if you're looking for a way
out sell everything or become the best
salesman on the planet Crush that job
and my buddy's father is a former
Carpenter who's retired now and he only
takes on projects that he does for free
for people who are in need and so let
that be a way that you give back to your
community let that be
um a Ministry that you do great but you
have to pay your bills
so one question you guys talk about
being debt-free all the time in in this
case with a business I mean do you look
at that much debt and do you see that as
bad or is that yes yes because dude 2020
happens again and your government that
already has told you we'll tell you
again you cannot work
you can't go to work
those debt payments will still come true
so you're in a little season when you're
making money off those trucks I would
not hang on to that long term I'd much
rather a crummy truck that I own than
being in debt
um and trying to make my bills get rid
of it you're looking for a way out we've
got the way out great hour John deloney
thank you sir thank you James Childs our
fearless leader there behind the glass
and you America for listening this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
John deloney if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsay baby
steps go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
that's ramsesolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
relationships and your work triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
phone number it's toll-free it's your
call your life we're here to help I'm
Ken Coleman Dr John deloney joins me
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to Phoenix
Arizona to start this hour David is
there David how can we help
hey um my wife and I are starting to you
know consider more seriously buying a
home and I was just wondering we were
looking at getting a house with uh
additional belonging unit to use as like
a Airbnb I was wondering would it be
makes sense to maybe spend a little bit
more on a house if it can provide some
income no
I especially wouldn't plan on it I
wouldn't factor that into my purchase
price
yeah I here here I'm having some fun
with the quick no but John and I were
just talking about this in fact we
shared this on the show last week I
forget James with I may have been George
on uh Friday of last week but we we
showed some data out there where the uh
the VRBO the uh Airbnb that industry is
Contracting pretty seriously right now
on what people are able to charge
because there's more Supply than there
is demand and so this is too speculative
for you to say all right I'm going to
take on more debt in return for the
opportunity to get a little extra on the
rent that helps pay things off I just
think it's too speculative I think if if
it's me and John I don't know what you
think about this from a marriage
standpoint but I don't want to move into
a new house and then have tenants yeah
if you do fine I just sure wouldn't take
a mortgage out on it with the assumption
that the only way we make this mortgage
is by people renting out parts of our
house it also like Ken says let's say in
this phase of your life y'all want to do
that and then a family of three moves
down beneath you in your basement and
you're all excited and then your wife
comes home and says I'm pregnant with
twins and your whole life changes and
you don't want these people in your
basement you can't afford for them not
to be in your basement the whole thing
is a domino that just you can't see what
happens two years and three years and
five years down the road so I wouldn't
do it I wouldn't do it I wouldn't build
that in
okay makes sense
yeah it's uh
I think we've used it to vacation in the
past and and thought it seemed like a
decent idea
um and I I was thinking it from the
standpoint of it would allow us to uh
have more space as a family so we don't
have any kids right now if we lived
upstairs
and then rented out the basement for a
few years and then decided to have uh
have kids we can then you know get rid
of that additional income and have the
more space sure I think you see you rent
for a little bit longer I agree and then
by the house y'all want to buy I like
that or or hey if you want to if you
wanna to come up with some extra income
to go do these trips that you want to do
find a way to do that here's in on paper
it makes total sense as John said but
bottom line is is you're assuming some
risk that is unnecessary this is like
just going I think I want some more risk
in my life and and I just don't think
it's necessary to accomplish what you
want to accomplish it doesn't make sense
to me it's too much risk the other thing
about you David and your wife y'all are
probably
pretty good
um
renters you probably took care of the
property y'all really gracious of your
host family y'all were honorable tenants
and you paid your bills and y'all are
not everybody
y'all are not everybody the landscape is
littered with folks who
have accepted people into their homes
and they live very differently than the
rest of us yeah so so be it yeah a lot
of Opera a lot of opportunities for this
thing to turn sour when it makes sense
on paper but then the emotion and
everything you want to get your own like
I got a buddy who he's got a second
property paid for and he airbnbs it out
as as his knock your lights out yeah
that's wouldn't do it in my house yeah I
agree Juliana is up next in Houston
Texas how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call
um I was calling my husband and I have
been married for five years now and um
life is about to change quite a bit from
what we've been used to he is going to
be leaving his full-time job to go back
to school and just be working part-time
and we've crunched the numbers and done
all the things and you know we'll be
okay but there's a couple of things that
are causing a little bit of worry in my
mind and I would just kind of like some
advice sure on what you might suggest to
do yeah what's he going back to school
for
uh engineering
okay and he has a degree currently
um but
changing of careers and gonna go back to
school wait wait wait wait what's he
going from to he has a degree in what
what's his degree in in biblical studies
so
um it's a long story he's in the
ministry right now full time but just
doesn't really see it as a full-time
vocation okay so just gonna step back
from that and pursue something more in
the secular world so what are you
struggling with
Okay so
have
the truck
so that brought our savings down to
around 12 000 now
we have a 420 a month car payment that
is our only debt which is my car we
bought it last year so we still owe
about 25 000 on it
um and my thought is should we trade it
in and pretty much break even and pay
something cash so that we erase all that
going into the season yes no longer two
incomes yes yes
what you have to look at when y'all when
you all decide to do this you all have
to look at the entire impact on the on
the impact on the entire household
it can't just be a dollars and cents
situation with okay his job will be able
to make it on my salary for this many
years and then we're going to be able to
not we won't do any retirement we're
just going to get through here we're
going to cash flow this that's part of
it but there's an impact to the entire
system of the house that you'll have to
take into consideration
mm-hmm I am a little concerned about
potentially being
all of the things it does say that it's
right at the 25 000 Mark and so if I
walk in somewhere I'm nervous that I
wouldn't get the amount that's owed on
it and you have to pay out of pocket to
pay off the loan and then buy something
cash and then our savings just plummets
down to nothing basically and so that's
what taught me nervous is you know I
like the idea of having it erased and
being done with it and it's not the car
I'm not attached to it in any way but
just the would it be putting us in a
position where if something does go
wrong in some other area of our life we
don't have the money then you're already
in that position
because you have a 450 a month car
payment
now I did hear your language you said if
we walked in somewhere so if you're
talking about taking it to a dealer
you're not going to get Kelly Blue Book
value for that are you aware of that
they're going to offer you way less
because they've got to make money on it
put on Facebook Marketplace so that's
where you get the blue book value is
selling in private sell it seller that's
the only way you got a shot of getting
the 25.
all right the Dealer's not gonna work
but let's say you sell it for 21 on the
open market
you're still in a better off position if
you go get what we call a credit bureau
credit bureau and you get a small
thousand dollars to pay off your car now
we've lowered our payment so we're still
getting out of debt so you guys have a
couple of options I want you to hang on
the line we're going to get you a
session with one of our financial
coaches uh because you've got some
complexities here and I want you to have
a session with one of our coaches
they'll walk you through every step that
you need so hang on the line and thank
you for the call this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
Dr John Delaney joins me as well it's
triple eight eight two five
two two five that is the number to jump
in triple eight eight two five five two
two five talking about your life your
money your relationships and your work
John joins us next in Indianapolis
Indiana John how can we help
hi there I wanted to thank you guys so
much uh first for taking my call you bet
how can we help today
so I have been agonizing over this
question for about a year now and it's
uh time to make a decision
I have been a traveling nurse
um obviously I'm making good money doing
that and
uh however uh a few years ago I I think
two years ago I scored really well on
the LSAT and I got a
a 70 scholarship to go to law school and
you know everybody I talk to they think
oh wow you know that's great you know
you're a nurse you know because you're a
nurse and then you go to law school and
you know you're definitely going to find
a job and
um but you know I'm making a lot of
money as a traveling nurse now you know
it's it's not the same as I were to stay
and you know Indianapolis for example uh
would not get paid as much
um and you know at some point I I wanna
I wanna I wanna you know play my route
somewhere and I just I think I'm
concerned because you know
on the one hand I I I'm familiar with
working in the hospital that's that's
what I know that's what I know how to do
and I've been doing it for 10 years now
and what inspired you to to go take the
LSAT you don't just you don't just rip
that one out on a whim
[Music]
I
keep I wanted to keep advancing I
thought about going to medical school
but you know the the time commitment on
medical school would be John I'm gonna
take it John I'm gonna take a stab
because you never got to the question
that you've been agonizing about for a
year I'm gonna take a shot here
I think you love a challenge
and I think you thought it'd be
interesting to see how you did you did
way better than you thought or maybe you
did as good as you thought you got a
scholarship you told people about it and
now everybody's so excited you've got
some sense of I kind of got to walk
through this or people are going to
criticize me and tell me that I'm crazy
I don't think you want to be a lawyer at
all and I don't mind if I'm wrong but
that's my read
yeah that's what other I and I want the
reason I'm calling you guys is because
you know I I know that you don't know me
and you know you're going to give me an
unbiased answer and that's also what
someone said John you answer you tell me
we don't get
out of Busters only reason I stepped out
on the ledge ledge you're having such a
hard time owning this thing that I think
your heart's telling you so was I right
or am I wrong
I
I don't know because I don't know what
being the job I think that's the main
problem is I don't know what the job is
like I don't know if I would like it all
right I'll tell you I was the dean of
students at a law school for years okay
sorry I was a dean of students at a law
school for years okay so I'll tell you
exactly what it's like
it will be incredibly challenging
you will write more than you have
written in your entire life you will
read more than you have ever read you'll
be surrounded by people who are
the the most the Brilliant Minds hardest
working folks and they will be single
single-minded on getting
um the right scores and the right
placements in the right places
highly highly highly competitive
and you will get to sit with some
hurting people which you've done your
whole career and you'll get to help
people you'll also be frustrated by big
systems which you've been your whole
career and so let me let me go ahead and
clear any doubt in your mind you can do
this
that's not the question that's right the
question is do you want to it will be a
commitment and I will also tell you that
my research was on the mental health of
attorneys and when you get partners
someday
the research tells me that Partners turn
back and go I gave up my 20s and 30s for
this and so you have to ask yourself not
for some future gain somewhere down the
road do I want to spend the next three
years of my life reading 16 hours a day
in writing and wrestling with hard
Concepts learning to work with the least
of these in our communities or help with
insurance companies or big business
whatever it is you want to go into oil
and gas whatever the thing is
and ultimately am I going to make this
through your commitment and go all in
and if you're not defer your enrollment
it's a it's a buyer's market right now
for law schools there's more seats in
law schools across the country than
there are applicants you're going to
qualified applicants
um you'll be fine with your LSAT score
people will take you from all over the
place and by the way if you've got a 70
at one college you may get a hundred
percent at another college
John
I don't think you want to do it you know
I don't think you want to do it
because I think this is Fascination for
you and I think you know what law school
is going to be about I think you know
the time commitment but I don't I don't
think that you really really really want
to practice a certain type of law you
might but I'll tell you how you find out
you need to start hanging out with a lot
of different laws go hang out with
lawyers like let's go hang out with an
employee employment uh law specialist
let's let's hang out with a defense
attorney let's hang out with a
prosecuting attorney let's hang out with
somebody who does real estate law I mean
there's so many different types of law
just as there are different types of
nurses I got to tell you I wouldn't
pursue this at all until you hung out
with enough people to go now that that
over there that's worth all of the stuff
that John just gave you a beautiful
description of see because on the other
end of that you gotta actually like what
you're doing or you're gonna go huh I
did this for the challenge I climbed the
hill now I need another Hill to climb
and you're calling us back three years
four years five years down the line
that's my concern and I'm not trying to
to talk you out of this I'm trying to
get you to fight for this because a guy
who really wants to be a lawyer has
thought about this a lot if I can talk
you out of law school you probably
shouldn't go that's exactly right and I
also want to tell you this the world
needs great attorneys and I want
brilliant people to be there if somebody
hurts me or my family to walk alongside
me me and my family I I need that and
you could be that person and I heard you
offhandedly say you did get into another
law school and you got 100 full ride
no you don't otherwise you'd be you'd be
over it I think you said you wanted an
objective opinion and I think John and I
are giving that to you we don't hear
enough of a heart behind this to put the
effort and the time into this and it's
okay see that's what I'm hearing and I
could be wrong but but I hear a guy who
feels the pressure
of
what people are going to say when you go
yeah I did this and I'm walking from
this because I actually like taking care
of people in the medical field I don't
want to travel as a nurse for much
longer because I want to change my
lifestyle and put down some roots
but I think I like taking care of people
in a medical context more than I do in
illegal that's what I think I'm hearing
I could be wrong can you go get your
nurse practitioner degree
would that give you peace
I I well you know I have thought about
um other paths I thought about you know
continuing to be a travel nurse and just
take online MBA courses hold on let me
ask you this let me ask you this is
there a Prestige element to this
yeah I would say I mean that's just how
my I think my Natural Energy so I'm
going to tell you right now brother do
not go to med school if the only reason
you're going is to be a doctor do not go
to law school if you just want to tell
people you're a lawyer amen go because
you want to help people have a better
life
The Prestige game I'm telling you I've
got two phds brother I chased it my
whole life until I finally broke down in
front of a counselor
and she said congratulations you made it
now what
you will never chase down the prestige
you'll never catch it it's a moving
Target it moves and it moves and it
moves and you'll move from one Law Firm
to another Law Firm to another paycheck
to a different suit to a better car and
you'll never catch it do what you want
to do you're so brilliant and you're so
bright and you have a heart for people
let that be enough man
John I want you to answer three
questions on your own before we go to
bed tonight who are the people I most
want to help but problem or desire do
they have what solution to that problem
or desire fires me up
now hang on the line we're going to give
you my get clear career assessment that
I think is going to help unpack a lot of
that appreciate the call but don't go to
law school you don't want to and
everybody knows it this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Dr John deloney and we
are thrilled you're with us triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services neighborly has 19 service
Brands Nationwide and a network of local
service pros Molly made Mr Rooter
plumbing and Mr Appliance just to name a
few by the way I will never be called
any of those names you know I'm Mr
incompetent around my house you know
that's why I need neighborly you know
visit neighborly.com to find available
service providers near you all right
today's question comes from Tony in
Florida Tony writes any advice on dating
went on baby step two Tony you lucked
out asking these two Tomcats
any advice on dating when on baby step
two I've been on several dates and it's
getting extremely frustrating and
expensive to take women out oh boy
where do we start here uh he's been on
several dates and getting extremely
frustrated and expensive well this is
called inflation my friend we'll start
there everything's a little bit more
expensive these days gas groceries I
mean you know I had to go uh clothes
shopping for uh my kids as we're already
starting to think about next school year
everything is more expensive right now
so uh advice on dating on baby step two
maybe you shouldn't date maybe you
shouldn't date you know you you we
mentioned this David said this how many
times over the last few decades you know
when you're in baby step two your
gazelle intense you don't see the inside
of a restaurant unless you're working in
one you know and so maybe Tony this is
the time to realize my dating life gets
back online when uh I have no debt when
my financial life gets online yeah or
um you're in Florida you can go on Hikes
you can go kayaking you can go for walks
you're gonna have to figure out free
dates and here's what's cool about that
you'll find out if she really likes you
or not
if she just wants to go out with you
because of the restaurant uh you're
taking her
probably doesn't have a lot of legs to
it the relationship and so uh
may want to pass all right so brother
you have you have a you have a great
window into the heart and mind of the
people you're dating because if they
don't again if they only like you how
much you spend on them
this yeah I wouldn't do that yeah I
think that's actually a great technique
you know you just tell these people
you're trying to get debt free tell
these women and so I would love to go on
a uh a Sunset Beach Walk With You
and uh we'll have some carrots and
celery and a little bit of hummus and
let's see if this girl wants to go out
with you because if she'll go out for
carrots and celery and hummus on the
beach though there's something there and
if you're listening to me and Ken
Babylon here and you're wondering how
did these guys get married we ask
ourselves that same question I actually
know the answer uh while Sheila and
Stacy are both phenomenal women anybody
who knows them would say so they also
lack judgment exactly so and man my wife
fell shorts the old uh hummus and celery
and kitchen trick oh I like that I
didn't do that Sinker baby yeah there
you go I didn't have a chance I was so
broke that uh the the carrots I couldn't
have afforded it I picked Stacy up our
first date and it was freezing cold it
was a December evening and I didn't want
her to be cold
because I had such a cheap crappy car
but I realized in that moment wait a
second I can go knock on the door and I
could take the key out of the ignition
and it'll still run that's how crappy
the car was and so uh just took the keys
with me no one could steal it but we
took lots of water because that's what I
can afford there you go lots of walks
around the lake and it worked out we're
on 25 years you're on what year 21 21 it
and but the key here the lesson is
gentlemen find a woman with poor
judgment
that's that's the takeaway that's how
John and I got married so there you go
let's go to Jonathan now in Fort Wayne
Indiana Jonathan how can we help
gentlemen congratulations 21-25 I'm
coming up on 14. all right all right way
to go did you did you out marry yourself
as well
absolutely good for you all right what's
going on
well my uh looking for some Winston
today
um you have come to the right place my
friend I was gonna say we'll put you on
hold unless you uh set you up for
another day yeah Chris Wright and James
are in the booth you're probably gonna
want to talk to them if you want wisdom
what's up
so I'm looking for some tips and tricks
to talk
for me and my siblings to sit down with
my mom and my father on asking if they'd
be willing to take FPU
oh tell me more
so in the last month my dad got laid off
from his job uh and so they're kind of
struggling a bit financially
throughout their marriage we've noticed
my dad just handles all the finances uh
he is a finance major so he believes
he's got everything under control and my
mom doesn't have much insight into that
and so she has had a couple times where
she stopped by my sister's home uh
broken down crying she's really
concerned worried you know security
gland is spasming and uh so she's uh we
want to help out as much as possible and
would like just the way to approach the
conversation uh in the in the most
humble way that we can to encourage them
uh to go through the course sure man I
love I love the heart of your siblings
um what I would tell you is
it's been my experience that parents
don't like getting advice from their
kids especially on money and sex
and those are two situations two two
things that parents don't like to talk
to their kids about and they especially
don't like to get
um judgment or wisdom from them and so
if y'all sit down and have this
conversation I think it would have to be
from a place
of
this has transformed our lives and given
me and our wife our homes our new homes
so much peace and we know Dad got laid
off you know you're struggling we just
want to know we support you we gotta we
pitched our money in together we got you
this gift and
um it would really honor us if you all
went through it together
but it's gonna have to be a very
open-handed invitation because you
haven't been invited into this
conversation your dad hasn't reached out
and said hey man I need some help with
this
um it's y'all looking and there's going
to be some pride there there's going to
be some frustration there's going to be
some heartache there there's going to be
some I'm a finance major who do you
think you are there and that's just you
know that's just Dad talking but I would
do it very open-handed and say hey we
all pitched in and this is our way of
just telling you that we're thinking
about you this has made a dramatic
improvement in our lives and we wanted
to gift this to you
yeah and my mom's opened up about it uh
with the financing that she's concerned
should we do no it's her marriage maybe
encourage her it's her marriage my dad
it right it's her marriage yeah but what
he's asking here is since the mom has
opened up about it instead of HE and the
other siblings bringing it up she
becomes the they give her the support
say hey here's this course FPU we'll put
you guys and let her be the advocate too
I think you all know your dad better
than anybody do you think she's the best
one to bring it up
Jonathan
oh yeah well I I think because I've
heard Dave talk about before like it as
a wife and he talks about when Sharon
was terrified right if if she approached
my dad and was like hey I'm really
concerned on where we're at I'm scared
to support our marriage and where we're
going can we please take this class
together so something along those lines
yes and be able to coach my mom to
approach it that way
yes and there's a reason why after all
these years your parents have been
married she has not felt the strength or
courage to do that
and there's going to be things that have
happened behind closed doors that you
will never know
and so you can ask your mom or you can
tell your mom hey mom here's some
there's some helpful conversations that
we had in our in our house that that my
wife had for me if you're ever
interested in that I'd be happy to share
it with you
but the idea you've had this you've
replayed this conversation in your head
over and over and over again
but it's your mom's conversation to have
um and it's her marriage I love the idea
of of the kids coming together and
saying hey we love you so much hang on
the line I'm going to send you a a gift
card with FPU on it and a year of every
dollar app so y'all can give it to them
as a family and if your mom wants to do
that that's that's you all know your dad
better than any of us but I would not go
in there guns and blazing I would go in
there with an open hands and a humble
spirit and say we love y'all and we this
has blessed us and we think it can bless
you thanks for the call Jonathan this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Dr John deloney the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five our
scripture of the day comes from First
Corinthians 9 24. do you not know that
in a race all the runners run but only
one gets the prize run in such a way as
to get the prize our quote of the day
comes from Dean karnazes I hope I'm
saying that yeah man the distance did I
say that right guys in the booth I said
that right okay hey I jumped out on the
end of the uh Hooked on Phonics diving
board and got that one right thankfully
uh he's an American ultra marathon
runner and the quote is we have killed
our souls with comfort
instead of seeking fulfillment and
achievement wow excellent I agree with
that wow really good stuff Jessie's up
next in Los Angeles California Jesse how
can we help
cool hey Jesse cool how are we doing
Jesse hey good how you doing Mr Ken Mr
John thank you so much for the
opportunity to talk to you guys you bet
what's up
well um real quick try to give you some
context
um my life is a bit complex as as much
as I'm sure as everyone else but
basically the specific that I wanted to
focus on is I currently have I work two
jobs right now but one of my jobs I work
with a family member I'd rather not
disclose too much about it but basically
work with family member for the last
couple of years now
um I honestly entered this world of
construction I work with in construction
I'm not knowing a dime not knowing
anything basically kind of lost
um I entered it because I my my I guess
my place of work has been more creative
realm as far as making videos and all
that kind of stuff but I found myself in
Cove at times when there was no work
obviously at that time so an opportunity
came up to work and you know we needed
we needed to keep the money at that time
so I took the opportunity to work with
with a family member and
um basically just jumped in not knowing
a single thing
um and there was an in construction like
I said and kind of been in there for the
last couple years last three years now
and to be quite honest with you I I
don't know how to move around the
situation in itself I sometimes you feel
a little lost as personally what I
really want to be doing and I know you
have written a couple books about that
but kind of going around the situation
um is you know right now because
construction can be so volatile as far
as you know things going up and down and
prices here and there also management
wise how things are managed affect that
a lot more within company so let's let's
dive in real quick Jesse what what is
the situation you've referred to it but
what does that mean
so in detail it basically means that I
I guess I will disclose it in a way that
I left my father-in-law I worked with he
has a small company Construction Company
and it
has been going okay he's been trying to
manage it the best as he can
um and so getting these projects and
getting all this bit of work kind of
situated payments have been really slow
and so
um does that mean payment to the company
or payment to you
both okay so whatever whatever happens
with on the outside we don't get paid by
a cup by uh clients
um money is not flowing through Jesse is
it safe to say Jesse is it safe to say
that you're pretty frustrated but you
feel like you might be trapped because
this is your father-in-law
yeah that's probably yes that's most
likely how you could describe it okay so
the way you set that up earlier and I
want John to jump in on this because
this has got some really really unique
family and relationship Dynamics but
um you said I need to figure out how to
navigate or move around I don't I don't
know that this is a move around
situation I I think this is probably
going to end up being a move on
situation and you're gonna and John's
gonna give you some pretty good advice
here on how to do that but I and the
reason I'm saying that and I'm asking
this and then I want John to jump in but
but if if I guaranteed you today a clean
break
meaning no stress no whatever just clean
break no consequences you walk
father-in-law is great wife's great
whatever would you walk today
uh yeah honestly yeah the only
hesitation I'd have is I don't know
where to go to next well worry about
that that's secondary and I'll help you
with that but I want John yeah I don't
have anything to add oh you've you've
said it yourself Jesse it's time to go
yeah and I think you need to make peace
with that
um don't avoid the hard conversation
you're at a job you're not getting paid
man if this is any other boss
you would have already been raising hell
you work hard you don't get any money or
the jobs are sporadic you get a random
email or random phone call or random
text message hey tomorrow be so and so
at six a.m you can't live like that you
gotta have steady work to take care of
your family and support your family deep
down your father-in-law knows that too
so it's time to go I think it's a matter
of figuring out what's next is your wife
sure she's on board with this too
yeah she's been great um and a bit of
context this is where I would like to
say it's complicated and maybe not be
that complicated but
um because it's my father-in-law they
decided to put her under as the main
owner of the company this was before we
got married
um and then afterwards I mean honestly
she was already part of that she did she
did so to help his obviously to help him
out
um and kind of put him in a better I
don't know I don't know the real reason
other than her she's the primary owner
of the company
yes sir is she the primary owner but
he's like he makes all the decisions
he's the shareholder
yes sir wow so does that mean that she's
paying taxes on this and he's not
um but yeah it's actually an hour I
think it's an LFC right now does she
take any sort of disbursement does she
get paid at all in the back end of this
deal
supposed to but it hasn't been any
um
how do we call it hasn't been there
hasn't been any any process so here's my
concern she you and her are carrying 100
of the liability with absolutely no
payout the only reason you sign up for
something like this it's not Criminal
is you want to the benefit of the bottom
line payout which is awesome that's why
CEOs take the risk because they make all
the money if something goes sideways
they're they have insurance and
liability for for what happens you all
have all risk all risks
it sounds very eerily similar to parents
who take out credit cards in their kids
names
honestly with you guys I have known that
for a while and you know and to be kind
of strengthened again my you know I
trust in God and I've gotten counsel
before and I hear that too and but the
thing is you know that that relational
part I'm like I don't know what to do so
here's the deal brother here's the deal
or against it either no no no no
father-in-law already burned the
relationship you're still holding on to
the end of it
you didn't do this as the great saying
goes not by your hand but in your lap
your father-in-law George chose to set
himself up in a better position at the
expense of his daughter and her family
and then brought you along and says
you're one of us now you're one of us
I'm not going to pay you
or except sporadically I'm not going to
give you work except sporadically
and he's just keeping you hanging on and
hanging on and hanging on if this is my
house I would sit down with my wife and
I would strongly recommend we get out of
the partnership I don't want to be an
owner here and if it's an ownership
thing I'm gonna go sell my business to
somebody or I'll sign the deed over and
y'all can deal with it and you brother
go find another job
yeah I I agree I would just tell you
right now go get a job doing what you're
currently doing let's let's not worry
about what my future path is right now
I'm going to give you a couple of tools
that will help you with that but right
now it's like if I can do this and I'm
doing it for my father-in-law who's not
paying me first step is I want to I need
to get some stability and deal with that
financial piece first so that I go work
and I just gonna go get a job getting
paid doing something I know how to do
then we clean this mess up maybe we need
to get some legal counsel on unraveling
this deal just to maybe get a consultant
like let's get a lawyer on this and
let's figure this thing out
um but we need to have a hard
conversation with the father-in-law as
well as John said I'd unravel this deal
and then let's figure out what your
future looks like to that end uh hang on
the line Austin's going to get you a
copy of uh actually an assessment code
the get clear assessment it'll help you
with Direction the book from paycheck to
purpose will help you with next steps
but as John said hard conversation
tonight you and your wife need to decide
what it is we're doing and inform the
father-in-law getting with an attorney
would be really wise just to look at the
structure of this Arrangement yeah
don't talk to father-in-law until you
all have your decision made and a path
forward and then you're going to let
them know what you're doing he is Dr
John deloney I'm Ken Coleman and this is
the Ramsey show thank you for listening
foreign
[Music]
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]